so there's a poem called the coyote or
the coyote depending where you brought
up and it has to do with a coyote I came
across so on one evening in Vermont
and my dog didn't seem to notice the
coyote and that's really at the core of
this poem trying to make sense of that
moment I mentioned the game of marbles
keepsies
the marbles one kempt of one one and
eight so the coyote veering down the
track like a girl veering down a cobbled
Street in the Meatpacking District high
heels from the night before black shawl
of black tipped hares steering clear of
that florescent ring spray-painted on an
even stretch of blacktop like a ring in
which we might once have played keepsies
veering down the track without the
slightest acknowledgement from Angus the
dog lying in a heap on our porch like a
heap of clothes lying beside at the end
Angus
who had himself been found wandering by
the highway somewhere on the far side of
Lake Champlain slub referred slam rican
bang boom showing through and though we
didn't know what when we brought him
home blind in one eye the right one the
one between him and the coyote the
cloudy floor flickered marbled of that I
know turning on you and mean taking in
the spray-painted ring where you and I
knuckle